[Musique]
j'adore j'adore fait tantôt d'accueil
oui mais bien sûr tom sera mc ça
cartonne aussi sur france télévisions ça
va être rachid ammar qui ma présence
vise la bonne idée me fait même le soir
formidable journalistes et avec demi
crise et d'ailleurs qui a été vraiment
fait de l'époque ce fin de la rentrée en
thèse on commence avec cristina cordula
et on se pose une question et elle était
là en danger sur m6 c'est vrai qu'elle
enchaîne des émissions qui ne marche pas
très bien on a fait un petit récap en
parle juste après il ya encore quelques
temps cette question ne nous aurait même
pas effleuré l'esprit mais aujourd'hui
on est en droit de se demander si
cristina cordula est encore
indispensable à m6 ne vous énervez pas
questi nahon vous explique
après avoir connu de nombreux succès ces
dix dernières années avec ses émissions
nouveau look pour une nouvelle vie et
les rênes du shopping c'est génial
oui ça se gâte un peu en ce moment pour
cristina cordula qui a essuyé plusieurs
échecs consécutifs la sara à des points
d'abord les rênes des enchères en 2019
le programme censé concurrencer affaires
conclues sur france 2 a tenu à peine une
semaine avant d'être déprogrammé à cause
d'audiences pas très magnifique en
octobre dernier l'animatrice était à la
tête d'un nouveau rendez-vous en prime
time
baptisé objectif 10 ans de moins les
missions du ga moral par une partie du
public a fait un gros flop en audience
1,6 million de téléspectateurs pour ce
premier numéro
non et à etterbeek culé discrètement en
deuxième partie de soirée par la chaîne
c'est choquant choc et même son émission
phare les rênes du shopping semble
souffrir cette saison en 9 fédéraux p770
les spectateurs en moyenne contre 1
million il ya deux ans à leurs audiences
mitigées et mission annulée cristina
cordula est elle en danger sur m6
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la désunion et les émissions fonctionne
il fonctionne un peu moins magali bas
effectivement on en a ras-le-bol de
cristina cordula lenteur dans la
puissance non elle et elle est
certainement très sympathique et encore
que non j'ai eu des informations des
équipes de prod2 de gens pour toutes on
fait les tournages avec elle ou il
paraît qu'elle est exécrable qu'elle se
prend pour une strate une star pas
possible peut-être qu'à un moment donné
les gens en ont marre justement de cette
de ce côté hautain de ce côté avec son
accent son machin qui ont travaillé avec
elle
ils ont au contraire qu'elle est plutôt
sympathique mais pas très bien écouter
ce qu'on voit c'est au delà de ça je
pense qu'il ya des gens qui sont
fédérateurs ont parlé vendredi dernier
de stéphane plaza stéphane plaza il
plaît à tout le monde y rassemble
cristina cordula c'est une personnalité
qui peut diviser elle peut agacer
c'est vrai qu'à cette taxe en attaque
[Rires]
mais dans l'ensemble c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui que les gens aimaient
beaucoup je pense que les missions qu'il
a fait beaucoup de mal son objectif 10
ans - partir en matière commencer une
grande partie des ménagères qui la
suivait qui n'était pas prête pour ce
genre d'émission
parce qu'on n'est pas encore prêts pour
les émissions de chirurgie esthétique
que moi j'adore perso mais je pense que
voilà donc les gens ont dit aïe aïe aïe
ouille ouille ouille à kaléya des nanas
celui-là non mais pardon il ya deux
femmes qui sont en train de vraiment
prendre deux qui ont toute la place sur
m6 c'est ophélie meunier qui prend une
place énorme avec zone interdite et
karine le marchand qui ramène le
dimanche surtout que ces accords du lac
devient un peu ce que tu disais une
caricature d'elle-même c'est à dire
c'est toujours pareil et je braille de
plus en plus fort et surtout ce qui
luttent dessert je pense beaucoup
c'est toutes les publicités qu'elles
chez du matin au soir on la voit sur
toutes les publicités pour du shampoing
pour regardant la télé mais c'est vrai
que je pense que vraiment c'est too much
et à l'oeil alors à stéphane plaza aussi
fait la publicité il est dans toutes les
questions ne savait pas français
professionnelle nicolas schwarzkopf
bassine verte issement que pensez-vous
de cristina cordula j'ai rien à penser
d'elle je pense juste que il faut
arrêter de la programmer de la
déprogrammer changer les horaires de
pioneer danger est donc propre et dépend
elle est pas en danger elle elle fait
très bien son job maintenant c'est vrai
qu'il faudrait commencer à la stabiliser
un peu sur la chaîne et recréer un
rendez vous c'est peut-être aussi le
conseil qui attaquent les rênes du
shopping c'est peut-être un peu à bout
il faut peut-être alors les rênes du
pays membres on vous a sectionné un
petit extrait c'est vrai que quand vous
voyez un extrait vous avez envie soit de
casser la télé une fois de casser la
télé regardez moi ces choux et moi c'est
tout
on est les lucho allait lucho ou à l'efb
à 3h 350 euros on est les lucho pnd ils
sont cinq rôles et lucho à l'ailé lucho
chanteur
[Musique]
voilà allez comme d'habitude au coeur
bonjour c'est les lucho pour les rênes
du shopping et amis c'est nous la mode
c'est nous les riches big c est ce que
tu as lu l'on sait que se posent des
questions puisque pour une émission qui
s'appelle un club pro forma tion ils ont
fait appel à des spécialistes qui ne
sont pas le caisson moissy sénart déjà
justement parce qu'en matière de look
quand même ya des faux pas notamment
chez christian cordula mais ça serait
judicieux leur part de prendre un visage
masculin pour parler de mode et sublimer
les femmes les hommes font ça très bien
c'est une banshee fait chier de but et
le voulait à intervenir sur la mode
c'est un petit peu mon dada voilà je
vais intervenir matin et accroît de
transformation effectivement avec
nicholas walters qui agit en tant que
coiffeur de dans la jeunesse en train
d'arriver pézenas a fait plus de dix ans
qu'elle occupe la case du stylisme voilà
maintenant place aux jeunes et je pense
qu'elle s'est pris une grosse claque
voilà merci beaucoup pour cette petite
intervention de la formation kazakhe
rebondit alors on va passer maintenant
ah bon on va passer les traders on va
s'intéresser à cette émission objectif
prise en moi c'est vrai que quand on
voit les missions 11 offrandes si m6
quand même ils n'ont pas un petit peu
chargé la barque parce que honnêtement
évidemment il est où les gens lui
redonner un accueil à la personne
regardez bien ce moment moi je suis la
dame en question je rentre chez moi je
le pense alors quel âge lui donne-t-il
qu'ils donnent 56 ans parce que elle a
beaucoup de ridules sur le visage sur
les côtés des yeux sur le front
également et a vraiment un gros lifting
même à refaire un génie 52 ans parce
qu'elle est le très très fatiguée des
yeux rouges le teint terne les joues
plus ou moins creusée et la façon de
soutenir montre qu'elle est vraiment
fatiguée
l'aspect général je dirais pesté à salé
elle est un petit peu négligents non
donc c'est fou quoi comme vivantes
oui tu as quel âge j'ai 44 ans j'ai un
désamour même si à la longue
44 on a mis un petit moment de la
transformation et là franchement vous
allez voilà personne j'ai pas si louis
n'envisage très peu d derrière où
quelque chose n'est pas d'aider des dd
je sais pas ce qu'ils ont envie d'être
des agrafes
c'est franchement savez tous beaucoup
dans ce programme de rajeunissement
nanciers a subi des injections d'acide
hyaluronique dont les tempes pour
remonter ses paupières et rajeunir son
regard et dans le nez pour en rectifier
sa forme et le rendre plus droit
son sourire a été retravaillé grâce à
des facettes et un blanchiment
nancy s'est également entraîné pendant
des heures pour retrouver meilleure
posture
les rats année jean
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on lui donne 34 ans soit 22
ans de moins qu'au début du protocole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notamment ils donnent 50 contre la sepa
disant moi c'est 20 ans moi la dame a dû
faire la même chose mais là il faut la
jolie franchement il faut faire
attention c'est d'une cruauté s'était
même si la personne ça l'aide à se
sentir mieux non je suis d'accord je ne
sais pas non plus de la personne de se
rajeunir transformer mais entre se
rajeunir et ce à la commission